[Music]
and so st. Maximus explains that all
things have a logos which are which is
its reason for existin its purpose and
its origin all at once and even its end
so it's all those things at once and on
top of that each thing has a multitude
of Logie that's a word you've probably
never heard before
Loki is the plural of logos and so the
the Loki they're like the different
qualities of things so the blueness of
the blue are the slowness of the slow
and all of these slogans are brought
together they're woven together we could
say to sustain the existence of the
world it's really a map of meaning to
use Jordans words
now these Logie these essences let's say
of things they don't exist independently
in the same way that scientists believe
things exist out there rather they exist
as they come together as they are joined
together in our encounter with the world
in a pattern we could say so we could
say for example like that a sunset has a
certain amount of loci maybe even an
indefinite amount of characteristics of
a sunset but as they come together to be
the experience of this sunset that's how
we experience reality that's how we
become into contact with reality so all
these qualities that's a light-colored
vertical horizontal and the things the
Sun the sky the earth all of these
things and I could go on there's an
indefinite amount of them what's
important in making that experience real
is how all those Loki's are united so
and in a way they're they're united
within us and human beings for
accidents are seen as this laboratory
where the whole world finds its cohesion
and he expresses it in the sense that
the human being is a microcosm you could
say a condensation of the cosmos so the
place where the cosmos comes together to
make sense and a good way to see it is
is that human beings actually
participate being in the image of God
they participate in creation we see that
in the book of Genesis the book of
Genesis God tells Adam to name the
animals and so by his logos
participating in a limited way in the
same manner that the divine logos was
the source of everything and the human
participation in this process is not a
relativistic thing it's not an
individual thing I mean though it is
flexible it's nonetheless the most
objective of processes as father Ted
mentioned and so we need to be cautious
though because st. Maximus warns us that
it's not just a philosophy or it's not
just a technical description of the
world this is important because thinking
that religious stories are exactly the
same kind of encyclopedic knowledge of
modern science is the wrong way to go
with this these logos these truth about
things are are categories of our
engagement with the world so maybe today
we might call them phenomena sent
phenomenological categories and so the
discovery of truth of logos it's a
personal journey
it's simultaneously a refinement of our
understanding of the world but at the
same time it becomes a refinement of our
person so to discover the true nature of
things is to walk on a path of truth so
food is a wonderful thing and it's
useful for life but gluttony leads to
our destruction
wealth is useful to accomplish important
things but
rots the soul so you see it's not just a
description of the world it's a path
that walk as we discover the world and
so sin in this vision of the world at
horrible world that horrible word that
no one wants to hear sin isn't just the
breaking of arbitrary rule but it it's
in the misuse of the world and that
misuse of the world ends up being an
untruth ends up being a liar or
something that's false something that
separates things from each other
it's found when things are not aligned
with their purposes so for example a
person is not only a tool for my own
gratification person is not just a tool
so that it can advance myself in the
world and if I treat a person
exclusively like that then I will
inevitably sin against that person I
mean of course it doesn't mean that a
person cannot act as a tool for my
gratification if I go see the Baker and
I get bread from him he's the method by
which I get my bread but the baker is
not just a baker he he is a full person
just as myself so when we steal or rely
or vici it's because we're not
considering to pay the person facing us
to be a full-blown person to be what
they are according to their logos but we
see them only as limited things only as
tools so this is true of people of
things and of actions so I was thinking
about I was trying to think about the
best example that I could think of to to
show this in terms of action and and and
I thought of giving the example of of
sex so we did the metaphysics of peppe's
so I think we can get away with the
metaphysics of sex I hope
but it's a question that desperately
needs to be answered today in our
topsy-turvy kind let's say so what is
the logos of sexuality well it has many
loci many purposes it's for the
propagation of the species I hope at
least a few of you still think that
despite what many people would want us
to believe it creates families and
communities it brings two people
together and the type of communion in an
expression of love and it brings
pleasure those so those will be would be
some of the lobby I'm sure we could find
more but some those would be some of the
loggia that sex exists and there could
be more
but the idea in division of logos is
that all those things need to be brought
together in a pattern of some sort
for them to be a path towards logos so
if we think of the different loci and we
bring them together trying to think of
the word what does that work when we all
those things are together I think we
have a word sacking of the church I'll
let you figure it out what it is when
all those things come together and so
each of the separate purposes of sex
that I mentioned they're not wrong
they're fine but they become alive when
we bring them together if we don't then
each separate purpose appears as a kind
of falsehood it appears a kind of
lacking but that's not enough let's say
for a truly traditional or a truly
complete vision of sexuality it cannot
end there has to move towards the
infinite it has to move towards God and
so the ultimate logos of sexuality is to
be an image of the mystical union with
God I mean it's to be an image of our
union with that with with what is beyond
us I mean that image of the mystical
union of
with the soul with Christ with his
church the marriage of heaven and earth
is a completely traditional image that
we find in in in the Church Fathers or
in our tradition and so that that image
of the ultimate union the highest union
with the infinite then it comes back
down into the multiple logo all those
other reasons for sexuality that I
mentioned and it fills them it makes
them participate in a transcendent
purpose and becomes the very
relationship that binds them together
and everything in our life can follow
that process work food sleep beauty and
to engage the world in that frame is is
to find light everywhere to see life
everywhere the world is no longer made
of the dead lifeless dirt the dead
lifeless material that we used to to
make things with and as we become better
as people more truthful more grateful
more free as we come closer to one
another in love and by the way that's
what love is love is the manner in which
all different things all different
people all different intentions can join
together and exist in communion and can
become one while at the same time
preserving the multiplicity so as we
follow this path the hidden Logie in
creation they shine through the world
and today we might say that they rien
tant the world and the world appears
bright and full and not the grey and
dead shadows we often live so that would
be I hope a summary let's say of that
path of logos
you